us they coming to the mic talking about
the food they hate talking about the
food they like two Fool's gonna fight
but only one food can be right people
from high school they they if they
Google Robert Kelly or Bob Kelly they're
not finding you no they're finding a
black guy that pissed on a bunch of 13
year olds is that what yeah it [ __ ]
kills me because I I finally yeah
I don't know I mean disappointed limo
guys are in Vegas when I come down to
ground zero and they're just like I'm
like what's up they're like ah [ __ ]
I thought we're gonna have fun that's
just me with my earpods talking to my
wife how's Max
yeah the whole back seat's covered in
trash bags yeah yeah wow I didn't
realize his name was Robert Kelly yeah R
Kelly so I will get popular on Google
and then this [ __ ] would you know
somebody else and all of a sudden it's
just him so you would you say you've
benefited or not benefited not
but what about before he was did you
benefit from a Google search you know I
have people from Africa that send me
love mail like I love I love your music
so much and it got so much where I
started just responding as R Kelly I'm
like thank you so much for believing in
me did you really yes yeah you should
have yes that's fine amazing thank you
for believing me man I I work from God
and I'm trying you know stuff like that
like I think RK would say you know
that's what that's what you would think
he would say yeah they of course thank
you for believing in me I work with God
yeah because it was a guy if it was a
girl it would have been like you know yo
baby right you'll be what you doing yo
baby you're catfishing people as R Kelly
yo baby I'm coming to Africa in a month
yeah
remember you ever see that that video
where he's on stage and he's going he's
going who wants to come back to the
states with Robert and he's singing he
was he was doing rape code he wasn't no
he literally goes he's used overseas and
he goes do you he was singing it it was
famous he goes do you have your papers
and then he goes did you get your shots
that that's the problem with R Kelly
that's why I never liked him he had such
a good voice he got lazy and he just
started going he's just going ah I want
Starbucks
is my drink I like to walk upstairs and
take elevators down
just stop [ __ ] talking yeah just
cause you could do a run on something
yeah this is it right here can we play
this without getting I'll buy you
something he literally just goes is
anybody out there single
can you put on captions
gotta hear what this guy says
yeah because he's he's literally took
two people home and they've never seen
them again yeah did you hear did you
watch any of that what did you watch any
of that doc that Force supports you
couldn't I couldn't do it surviving I so
I I turned when it was all the rage I
turned it on there there's a story
there's stories you won't believe this
here it is here it is
so shocks girl
you have your passport
did you get your shots
[Music]
America
[Music]
this is this is the craziest you can
show me a crazy thing than this listen
to me this is the ultimate there's
nobody around him to tell him he's a
[ __ ] idiot that's why I love being a
common one if I did that on stage if I
was like is there anybody wants to go to
Westchester
and go get a chicken club do you have
your Easy Pass do you have your booster
dude he he he's first of all no one
checked him his whole life you go back
now and you look at every song every
song is just like it's every song is
literally what he's been doing to women
for 20 years yeah I know he's just
telling you what the [ __ ] happened but
yeah so he says do you have your
passport do you have your shots girl do
you want to come with Robert to America
but then he does this
uh yeah it's like it's like he's
recruiting with a dress he's like dang
you know he got the carrot of freedom in
front of them you know when he got off
he was like this he was like this did
you see what did you see that new thing
I did like yeah like he's [ __ ] four
guys I feel bad I feel bad for the
people that have to tour with famous
people when they gotta go back and like
did you see dude when you did America
when you went America you showed him
where it was dude are you kidding me
dude with the America stuff dude you
could do that anywhere too not just not
just doing Cambodia Vietnam
yeah except America but you could do
would you like Europe and Europe be
something like this I like the girl in
the audience who's like I have a
passport I want to go to America I want
to go to America I uh I don't have my
shots my shots
[Laughter]
do you have your shots she slowly dies
yummy girls when I got their shots the
next day
[ __ ] did that piece of [ __ ] oh [ __ ] man
I never realized that you had the same
name he is so that is the laziest [ __ ]
ever look at him look at that outfit
yeah
um the worst he pulls up the worst R
Kelly lyrics and you got your good pimp
you got to switch on something
um but we're still good right right now
um my my name's not Vincenzo I will say
that I don't want to move forward
anymore like that what are you talking
about my name is my name that you know
yeah I was just bullshitting I was just
your name is not finchenza Vincenzo no
you were lying to me I was well I was
having fun it depends out which way you
want to slice it you know what my kid
just said oh I'm gonna slice it yeah I'm
gonna slice the way God slices it you
were lying yes
we're in a platform that that represents
a playful atmosphere oh God yeah
you're like my kid my kid lied to me and
I said you're lying he goes dad I was
joke lying oh
he coined that he coined joke lying yeah
so you would joke what do you lied about
do you remember when I was just those
all the time
um no I forget are you with the kid how
old your son now he's nine nine nine wow
that's one of the best stages right I
mean you're in the window of like every
single age I've had this is the problem
with having a kid everyone's dude the
best age is now the best day it's always
every if you love your kid right every
single age is the best age right I mean
I've loved every every goal every exact
graduation but now what's frustrating
with this age and it just happened this
week is that he's nine he has friends
and now you have to accept your [ __ ]
being broken oh yeah like I brought in I
bought a new uh 150 backpack really thin
Sleek it's got all the stuff in it and
he's one of his friends stepped on the
the clip and it's a special clip you
can't replace it so the bag's done
that's that's oh I'm gonna wear it with
yeah it's gonna be weird right right
right right and then our table we have a
beautiful yard in the backyard let me
just you should look contact the
manufacturer sometimes they have a
little bit of a warranty what am I 80.
I'm gonna write a letter
listen you can write to them like via
quill pen no okay just put it on a
messenger pigeon and just see if they
get the Buckle back my [ __ ] niece I'm
gonna get the money for the bag by suing
you have insurance right yeah but this
has nothing to do with me this place
operation
I really do feel like I'm in The Wolf of
Wall Street right now
your kids age do they know you now do
they look you up because they look up to
Stefano and they kind of heckle him
um no he knows me but he's no his
friends oh his friends no okay I don't
think so but he's very proud of me he's
been on stage with me he's in front of
17 000 people at the Boston Garden
that's amazing Stefano his kids teacher
or somebody was like oh he's not famous
he's not a good comic oh really oh they
never do that no no because I go to the
school and go listen you shut you you
never talk to my son like that again you
piece of garbage how dare they the
Stefano's one of the [ __ ] biggest
Comics what the [ __ ] what um I would
have I would have took him right out of
the school
hooked up a mic right there and just
started doing stand up in the holes just
making everyone laughing then they would
approved she would have been right I was
like yeah teachers right I was just
bombing in front of nine-year-olds you
told you this you killed speaking of
bombing killing you crushed one of the
hardest sets I've ever seen Crush I told
you this before I told you on your own
podcast right on our cruise on the
cruise yeah it was the one of the
hardest crushes I've ever seen I
couldn't believe it oh that was I mean
it was like one of those ones you just
like you see in like the movies where
people are just like the walls are shake
like people are falling out of their
seats it was crazy yeah that was it was
it was good and it was better and then
we were just like all on the side the
other Comics like just being like holy
[ __ ] dude and then Jay had to go on
after you big Jay had to go on after you
yeah but he's I mean anybody he's the
one he killed but I mean yeah he went
down he just sits he has confidence
somebody's somebody's just murdering and
saying hey how are you yeah yeah I mean
that's why Jay's confidence is out of
the room you've been you've been how
long have you been doing comedy if our
audience I mean I feel I feel like our
audience 100 knows he's a legend yeah
yeah no of course that's what I'm saying
like they're probably you don't have to
call me those I'm a legend
but to me yeah your whole that whole
group of you is to me I mean you get you
guys are the comics I grew up like
watching right and and I I before we
were ever friends I told you I've paid
to see you that's so weird isn't it
weird yeah that's so weird I remember
when we met officially was that like a
skank Fest like maybe like eight eight
years ago whatever it was yeah because I
remember it because I knew you you
didn't know me yeah you know when we
walked in you knew of the show we met
but prior to that I had seen you do
comedy
over the years 10 times no [ __ ] yeah
that's wild I remember when I first
watched your I watched your sketches
and then uh oh God no like the old ones
one of the funniest sketches I've ever
seen in my life and I still have it on
my phone yeah and I still play it and
it's genius
[ __ ] can I talk about it yeah okay
okay
South the the closet and it's so is it
it's so beautiful because you the closet
just has lights under the door yeah it's
a time machine yeah yeah yeah yeah and
you go into the time machine and there's
just Lights under the door whatever it
was just yeah
and then all of a sudden you come back
out and you'll be like well yeah what
happened was in the sketch um
James Murray who's on my show right he
goes uh so I we're roommates I eat his I
eat his leftover Chinese right he's
pissed off right so for Revenge he
builds a time machine goes into the
future yep and finds my future daughter
and has sex with her right and comes
back which is funny which is yeah which
is hilarious in itself right but the
reason I mean I mean that's that's crazy
penalty it's crazy that he built the
time machine and you and you believe it
and then you go on the same time machine
and come back and you go I [ __ ] your
son
and he hits his own leg I've never seen
a dance move like that and I do it once
in a while I can't do it now
there's 90 couches in here and it's like
I feel like I'm in the warehouse of Ikea
this is this is this is like good [ __ ]
yeah I [ __ ] yourself
I can't sing it because I'll sing it no
I almost sang it in front of my son yeah
because I [ __ ] your son and he [ __ ]
me back and I could just when you were
doing this oh this is [ __ ] terrible
but it was I think I took it down
offline but basically I I run in the
time machine after he tells me he [ __ ]
my daughter and I come back and he's
playing video games I sit down I'm like
you're not worried I went into the
future he's like no I'm not because I
don't care because I don't have a
daughter so I was like you don't I go
but you do have a son I go and I [ __ ]
you a son
and then I go and I didn't even just
have sex with him I said I want to break
his heart so I dated him for six months
and then I cheated on him
and then I I come out and I have all the
photos like I took I went out and shot
that so I came back and I show him all
the photos of me and his son and
everything
it's [ __ ] one of the funniest things
one of the funniest questions
if you watch it just watch when you slap
your foot yeah I don't know how that
came up you had to be pure excitement
from [ __ ] it was we just improvised
it and I was singing all this yeah poker
space it was all during the I was
singing I know it was um what was this
the song uh what's the song with red fox
what's the play thing with red fox
I [ __ ] your son oh is that it I [ __ ]
your son his name was crying
Sanford and Son yeah nobody knows that
except off no I know it's sad I actually
did a reference on stage the other night
and they were just looking at me like
what uh All in the Family yeah see the
thing is what do you actually bunker
they went who's that oh no I was like
[ __ ] that's bad dude
hey guys come see me on the road all
tickets are available right now at
savvalcanocounty.com uh my fall dates
are up to the end of the year I'm gonna
be next week I'm gonna be in uh Hamilton
Ontario and Toronto Toronto we've added
a show that's October 14th and 15th and
the rest of October we're doing the
Richmond Virginia the carpenter theater
Hershey Pennsylvania they added a second
show there that's selling fast
um
and that is all for October November
we're in Knoxville Atlanta and
Birmingham we're also in Louisville and
Evansville and then it rounds out in
December I'm going to Florida to Orlando
Jacksonville and Tampa and Tampa we
added a second show and I end the year
over in California I'm doing Santa Rosa
California San Jose California and we
are doing Sacramento everything's on
sale right now merch is up I got solo
merch and all the podcast merch is up as
well at salvolcanocounty.com hope to see
you guys on the road October we got dead
crow comedy club in North Carolina
in November I'll be going to Michigan do
a bunch of shows and I've got tons of
other stuff around that stuff and after
that stuff and coming up in the new year
and all that anyway you can find all of
it at jonarosainfo.com also if you're in
New York City please come to my bar and
sandwich shop Joey roses uh all info for
there is Joey
rose'snyc.com we're open six days a week
opening at 12 P.M every day great
sandwiches awesome hang and lots of
booze see I I I have that on stage I had
like I'm like oh this would kill if the
right order like I know I don't I don't
do the reference when I'm like I'm about
to do this reference like if it was an
audience of people our age
it would do great but I'm like I don't
want to yeah it's like going overseas
you have to like the first show is all
editing out the stuff it's all like
feeling they don't know what [ __ ]
Mercer Street is right they don't know
certain you got to take out the details
that make it America right right or New
York and then I have a bit about uh the
song The Rhythm Is Gonna Get You by
Gloria Stefan the Miami Sound Machine
you mean with the one with the Congo
drums yeah
well basically my my bit because when I
was younger
I was a terrified kid really and I was
when I was young I was I was actually
scared of the Rhythm because the song
that would they played it constantly it
was like you were scared that it was
going to come out on a train and he was
going to start dancing
tonight oh you thought the Rhythm was
scared like he's coming to get me yeah
really yes and I and I really really
like there was I was very scared when I
was little dude that's so [ __ ] nuts I
know but it was just like oh now or
they're like singing everything in the
Congo drums it feels a little haunting
and she's going the Rhythm Is Gonna Get
You there's the lyrics the lyrics it was
it was a you know the it was a sexual
song The Rhythm is gonna get you to
dance like you can't fight it I know
it's gonna go inside you and you're
gonna start well now I know now I'm
gonna be like no now I know that but now
back then I had no idea that I was
taking literal you know so did you have
a brother Three Sisters oh
but my mother when I was being bad one
time oh no
she picked up the phone and she went
yeah she went hello
yeah he's he's not he's not being good
at all hold on one second she went yeah
the rhythm's on on the phone to talk oh
yeah
she made me literally almost [ __ ] myself
I was sleeping with the lights on for
two years after that you were afraid of
the did you go to your like high school
dance
but be afraid of the rhythm's gonna come
down the wall listen to the lyrics
the Lyric's gonna get you tonight she
says in bed throw the covers over you
hadn't pretend like you're dead because
the rhythm's Gonna Get You Tonight
oh that is creepy oh he's angry
yeah maybe maybe you're right I'm
telling you all right let me see this no
clueless I might when you turn off all
the lights there's no place that you can
hide the rhythm's Gonna Get You in bed
throw the covers on your head pretend
like you're dead because you know the
Rhythm Is Gonna Get You there's no way
you can fight it no matter what you say
the rhythm's gonna get you you're gonna
have no clue of what's happening to you
and before this night this night is
through that rhythm is going to get you
I was [ __ ] myself the rhythm's gonna
every time that's worse than R Kelly I
heard Congo drums I would piss
you know what I mean but people don't
know what the song is what I was getting
at you couldn't even enjoy the Puerto
Rican Day Parade you couldn't even do it
I couldn't go anywhere where there was
Salsa my God people people would didn't
get it like if I do it for my audience
strictly I'll mostly get it but like
sometimes in a club or whatever younger
people they just and I have to like okay
so there was this song yeah you gotta
let that go yeah yeah that's the thing
where it's like dude ain't gonna work
that's like that joke I was using it as
a closer for a while you were yeah it
was it was closer yeah sometimes that's
still pretty funny yeah you've been in
crushes but the new fans are like what
yeah but but there's a fix you know you
just kind of spoon for you you should oh
this is how the song goes that should be
the song you come on to it's a song I
leave to is it yeah it's awesome great
it's [ __ ] great it's fun that's
really awesome
it was good it was one of those bits you
know that was like it was erode itself
which is the best that must explode the
crowd you do that bit it crushes and
then you play that song yeah and you
must you must go I mean thank you good
night you must feel like shot out of
there Michael Jackson isn't that the
best like when you have that type of
show and you say the perfect goodbye at
the perfect time when you do the joke
the crowd pops and go that's my time and
then they go
thank you you got to get him right on
that upswing and they're about to and
you say thank you on that and then they
go
so happy you could do one joke too much
too though I know
too much I want too much and if you and
if you don't get that film laugh I know
and then you walk off and I'm just going
it's like thank you good night and
they're like okay yeah yeah yeah rhythm
is gone again you know who's gonna be
dancing all right is there one in your
memory that's brutal oh yeah but the
worst one uh first time headlines
not a bomb okay ending okay where I
[ __ ] up yeah I got because I you know
look dude I had a
rough upbringing you know jail juvie all
that [ __ ] guys as if Amazon wasn't
convenient enough we now have Amazon
Pharmacy okay I when I want to go to the
drugstore I'm always there at the last
minute I'm always hoping they'll be open
the pharmacy always has different hours
than the actual drugstore sometimes they
get to the drugstore the pharmacy's
closed I can't stand it or I get stuck
in a line I get stuck in a line and then
they're discussing my medical history
out loud I don't love that in the
pharmacy
um that's why we love Amazon Pharmacy
yes that Amazon Amazon Pharmacy delivers
a better Pharmacy experience delivers
directly to your door with most
insurance plans uh so that's it you know
you're gonna save time you're gonna save
money and you're gonna stay healthy this
transparent pricing okay so you know
exactly what you're paying before you
pay it uh you can save up to 80 percent
if you're a Prime member on your
prescriptions uh and like I mentioned
earlier Amazon Pharmacy works with most
of your insurance plans and also check
this out if you ever have questions any
problems real pharmacists are always
available on Amazon Pharmacy see no
matter what time day or night that is
huge your medication goes right to your
door there's no more rushing out to the
store before they close a pharmacy that
works for your life with meds delivered
to your door doesn't get any better than
that switch to Amazon Pharmacy and save
time save money and stay healthy learn
more at amazon.com buds
that's amazon.com
buds amazon.com buds
average savings based on usage and
inside RX data as compared to cash
prices average savings for all generics
are 78 37 for select brand medications
restrictions apply boy oh boy do I love
bespoke post we talk about it um and I
get my box of awesome collections every
single month since they have started on
the Pod every single month I get a
bespoke's box I let them pick I don't
know what it's going to be I recently
got
um a an herb an herb growing kit which
I'm using to make like Rosemary and
Thyme in my own kitchen which is a lot
of fun that's great your prince prince
herb I am Prince herb and I am making
those hours
I got a fresh mozzarella making kit with
like these tomatoes that you grow it's
so cool and I got a really cool knife
I swear and I gave the knife to my dad
yesterday he came to visit and he
actually really really loved it a knife
and a neck tattoo yeah it's going wild
um from camping gear to Essentials to
travel even Autumn cocktail kits the box
of Awesomes have you covered for the
fall
um to get started take the quiz at
boxofawesome.com your answers helped
them pick the right box for you they
release new boxes every single month
across all different categories and each
box is valued at around 70 bucks but
because you joined the subscription
service that's where you save you you
only pay a fraction of that price so
you're getting these things in the mail
they're worth 70 bucks and you're paying
just a few bucks with each box of
awesome you're also supporting small
businesses because nine ninety percent
of everything that comes in your box of
awesome is from a small and up and
coming brand that's one of the best
things I like about this company
um it's free to sign up and you can skip
any month and you can cancel any time so
try it and it's fun just it's just fun
you get home and there's a box and you
don't know what's in it and it's fun
live life again really get 20 off your
first monthly box when you sign up at
box of awesome.com and enter the code
taste buds to check out that's box of
awesome.com code tastebuds for 20 off
your first box box of awesome.com code
taste buds I went back to Boston for the
first time headlining a theater for the
first time sold out
Wilbur Theater okay right when the
comedy connection moved from there to
here
I'm selling it out and I I do this show
and I'm [ __ ] killing and what that
means I mean the Wilbur is like a
comedic institution in Boston well it's
it's like it's like the room it's the
best room to play comedy in really it's
one of the best rooms and to be from
Boston it's like but it's a theme like
for me it was my I'm a club yeah I'm a
club guy so to play that theater in my
hometown and sell it out my family was
there you know it's like all the fans
were there and I I murdered and I said
good night at the perfect time and it
was like yeah and I was like and then I
talked again I got so emotional because
I was so oh you [ __ ] you you actually
quieted them down dude I went like I
started talking I went I want to let you
guys know uh that this means the world
to me
dude I kept going I was like you know
the and I heard a guy go oh boy
I know it's a special show and I want to
do that I try to do it like somewhere
like before the last bit or something
like that dude I ain't ever doing it
again I don't give a [ __ ] if I sell out
MSG I'm going thank you good night I'm
just standing like Eddie Murphy and I'm
[ __ ] walking off because dude I was
trying to get emotional I was trying
because it all overwhelmed me and I'm
just such a an [ __ ] and I just want
to say you know it's been a long road
what
you know I I had a hard time and now
that you supported me and I support and
if you can change and I can change then
the world like Rocky [ __ ] it's like
[ __ ] you I know
oh boy yeah oh boy and I saw his face
and he looked at his friend he was like
I was like I'm [ __ ] I'm a comic what
am I doing I know I'm getting Emoji they
don't care it's the Wilbur it's not the
garden I know I know what you mean yeah
they have a you ever walk off to music
and they don't play it
no and then so I'm like thank you guys
so much thank you and they start
clapping and then you're like thank you
and then they just don't play and you're
like all right and then they just like
clap and you kind of just walk off the
stage like kind of waving and then you
get off and the guy's like and then he
hits it the second you're off I'm like
what is that don't you work here like
the sound guys sound guys can ruin a
[ __ ] show and they have ruined them
oh they have they they sit there because
they think you're [ __ ] Lynyrd Skynyrd
right and they have to ride the micro
he's a little too high yeah
I do this yeah yeah I'm a professional I
know how to use this right like a
[ __ ] instrument this is my instrument
you [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
don't touch it you can hear you getting
happen to me goddamn uh Saturday night
the guy's just sitting there like this
and I I was like you can hear me go up
and down and then uh at the at the end
at the beginning too when they play the
song they don't you're walking Robert
Kelly and his Applause and then you're
halfway there and then they [ __ ] play
it's like you've got to play at the set
in it and they know that that's what I
don't get because sometimes I'll be like
oh there was a lag in the Wi-Fi they
have the same thing doctors have they
have a God complex because they know
that they could go boom and your show's
over yeah I got into a fight with a
sound guy we're doing creeps for kids in
Chicago
and uh the sound Sound and Lighting uh
they came out and he was uh we had no
monitors we had there was no lights on
the stage and we got a show we sold out
the theater and there's people there and
this guy took our package our sound
lighting package and brought it to
another gig
like literally set it up no that's the
only Florentine
the great Bennington and the legend Rich
Voss yeah
and uh is that coming back you played St
George with that did Saint George yeah
that's here in Santa yep yeah and uh
Jersey and um
this is Jersey Staten Island is not New
York it's Jersey well
I could see why you say that I can't
it's 100 Jersey I'm not I'm a New Yorker
but I can see what you mean this is not
it's like it's like it's in between
somewhere
absolutely not this is actually a
[ __ ] Jersey you refuse absolutely not
it's actually this is not there's
Brooklyn there's four boroughs okay oh
listen sore point
some sounds that want to Annex they
wanted to Annex because you're not New
York well we are New York though dude
that bridge I took is not new that's the
same Bridge you take to get to Jersey no
what did you take dude I took the the
[ __ ] Staten Island the one that
jumped off of or something yeah yeah
that's not New York that's the most New
York Bridge you could possibly take yeah
and then it's I mean becoming New York
when it's it gets in New Jersey if
Arizona is the longest suspension bridge
in the United States of America yeah and
it goes from New York to Jersey it
doesn't it goes from Brooklyn to Staten
Island from New York to Staten Island
New Jersey
standout has the best rated penises in
an online survey I mean hottest chicks
yeah of all the boroughs I think Staten
Island new Staten Island Jersey has the
hottest chicks yeah 100 who's that I
guess the woman who raided the penises
oh all right there you go
there was uh
just to draw a line on him with it
speaking of uh penises back to you son
Max
um whoa
[Applause]
I can't wait to play that for him by the
way but I was getting at earlier was
like at nine now uh do you know you you
have him down like do you know when he's
lying all the time does he ever get one
over on you this is all I have to do
here I'll go Max did you do that and he
goes no dad and I go
and he starts laughing his ass off yeah
yeah like literally my kid has a great
sense of humor he will laugh his ass and
be like Dad Dad I'm telling the truth
because he knows he he knows that
um lying is very important to me okay
and I said to him don't ever be a liar
you tell the truth man up to your [ __ ]
yeah because when you lie you break
trust and if you don't have trust you
can have a relationship with somebody
you think that he's absorbing that 100
yeah he's understanding he tells me when
you see of what you mean at 100 he tells
me when he's when he [ __ ] up he tells
I go owning your when you [ __ ] up I go
you're gonna mess up always yeah well
even when he does that like dude it's
okay you're gonna do this again just own
it right own it own it and and you can't
speak to him like that at nine I do yeah
I do because yeah and he's actually
become a very mature nine-year-old
that's great yeah like I came out
yesterday I was doing my podcast in my
little shed studio and I looked out and
he was he had uh uh Crystal Light and
wine glasses
[Laughter]
his friend was sitting there talking
like this
I literally had to get off I go guys
give me one second and I went out and I
go in the middle of the pocket I go what
are you guys doing he goes dad Jane
broke up with me yeah I threw slime in
her but it's all right no friends no it
took a sip and I'm like I'm gonna let
this go down I'm out
myself
[Laughter]
[Music]
crazy
oh we're talking over here he was made
why he knows what wine has been made
you know Crystal Light yeah Banger how
do you know Crystal Light Crystal Light
had its I mean Crystal lights Heyday was
like the 80s yeah I don't know maybe the
90s dieting as a teenager yeah yeah I
didn't I haven't I haven't thought of or
seen Crystal Light sometimes I always
travel with it wow because I have to
drink water a lot yeah and it helps and
it helps you even the littlest bit I
love doing it that's what I love doing
you put it in a get a water bottle take
that I already know I know what you're
gonna say can I say we're gonna say
please go yeah I love this game I want
to do this again because I think that's
what you do because this is what I do
what okay you take the water bottle you
put it you put the Crystal Light in the
water bottle already but then you drink
and every time you drink a little you
keep filling up with more water or no I
said it so basically what you're doing
is you're diluting the drink as you go
but you're getting the taste of you know
of it all the way down to the end less
and less and less but you could chuck it
because it tastes really really good I
like putting it up there because
everybody in the audience is going what
the [ __ ] oh you put it in what about
everybody's like what do I get to drink
and then you're out there with this
[ __ ] purple purple purple or
raspberry and it's there's no I take the
the banner off or whatever it just looks
like they're like what the [ __ ] I swear
to every show some people dude what were
you drinking yeah curious [ __ ] yeah do
you remember the Crystal Light jingle
from the 80s that was like heavy jingle
no tell me if this rings a bell to you
ready yeah I believe in Crystal Light
cause I believe in me yeah
that was a [ __ ] great jingle almost
as good as I [ __ ] just
look at these people this is a late
night swim with a with half nude adults
look how big look how big the package
used to have to be though look at that
Crystal Light Crystal Light that was
before we knew that that was just full
of aspartame right it's all white people
too this before they allowed any
minorities in anything look at how white
if you could go back and watch
commercials yeah from the 80s
representation here is not one there's
not even an Italian yeah you're right
we're talking Puritan yeah right Puritan
yeah we're talking little abuses I mean
look at it dude like yeah there's not
one it's all blonde chicks it's all it
was always a blonde girl what is going
on there exactly in this Crystal Light
commercial oh they just went from an
orgy and then they jumped in the pool
are they at the gym but then all of a
sudden the nightswing then look at what
you what's all that water splashing down
around her every commercial every
commercial was like the same set as a
porn set like that gym has been used in
porns that gym that they use in the
Chris that gym right there that scale
has jizz on it it has to be oh it's in
the that they do commercials like in the
valley in the valley yeah in the valley
that's what can I tell you the story
yeah please I don't know if I told it on
this oh hey babe but in 1995 yeah I went
to I took my first plane ride yeah okay
yeah I was like 18. I went to California
with my friends I stood there for a
couple weeks
my friend we crashed on my friend's
cousin's uh couch my friend's cousin
about 10 years older than us at the time
just signed a deal with Warner Brothers
his band was called sister whiskey and
they were rock and roll band and they
sign like a big deal with Warner
Brothers and they had a Hit Radio single
called Simple Man right okay I'm getting
to this part now no I'm interested he
had a friend yeah that was in the valley
that his job was house sitting for a
porn producer named Bruce seven who I
think has since passed God Rest his soul
right I don't know I don't know him
personally but yeah I tell Shane when
anyone passes right so so he he calls
him and says oh come visit me I'm house
sitting this guy's house in the valley
yeah it's this big beautiful house or
pool we can hang out I'm watching his
cats so we said all right so we go there
he lets us in this guy's long hair this
is when like boys like rock is in they
were all right yeah
he'll be like what's up guys come on in
he's like yeah just and you walk in and
there's a a long hallway with all the
vhs's like a thousand of them he puts
the guy has him in the front hallway
when you work with us all his porn wow
with all the awards wow on the shelves
right so I'm like all right this is just
out right in front as soon as you come
in the house right yeah so he's like I'm
watching his cats and he's like you know
he shows us around he's taking this is
the yard oh come down here cases down
holy opens the door it's like a it's a
huge huge walk-in closet
all sex stuff in there right and he goes
yeah he goes open that chest we open
it's a chest maybe 100 150 dildos in it
he goes my job's to clean the dildos too
so we're like all right that's funny
right so we go out and there's a
Contraption in the living room that they
built it's like a steel Contraption with
like ropes and it's like a sex swing
right in the goddamn living room right
and we're like that's unbelievable so
they must do do porn here so he's like
watch he takes out of cassette he puts
him with sitting on the couch watching
and they're having sex in the porn on
the couch that was sitting here and then
they use the contraption and everything
really and then he goes wait wait wait
check this out check this out and a hand
reaches in with a glove on it and a
hands a dildo he goes that was my hands
that was that was his mom actually I bet
he still does that by the way
[Laughter]
I know that should come for me I'm
actually a little [ __ ] uncomfortable
right now all right yeah well we were
from my son yeah sorry about that to the
kids done listen sorry about that kids
Crystal Light cause I believe in me
Jesus why is she drinking Crystal Light
in the pool
so refreshing it's refreshing and you
believe in yourself I I you still does
it have aspartame still they have they
have they progressed and found like monk
fruits man I don't know what I I the
aspartame dude I quit I quit drugs I
quit cigarettes I'm not eating shitty
you look
fantastic thank you very much buddy your
skin has a glow yeah I wouldn't just say
it oh thank you buddy I appreciate that
yeah just some beautiful cat oh thank
you man it's beautiful thank you I
really they it's like you can't get more
perfect you know my mother takes full
credit for it really yeah every 20
minutes I'd roll yeah I'd roll you over
it looks amazing guys I want you to
check out Rhone that's Roan r h o n e
they're a new clothing company that are
advertising on the Pod and they they're
all about versatility okay so if you're
going out for a happy hour if you're
going on a date if you're going to work
if you're going to an event if you're
leaving work and you want to be let more
casual these are flexible uh pieces of
clothing breathable comfortable flexible
clothing that's comfortable and easy to
to to wear feels good but it kind of can
transition from work to play that's
their big thing the dress shirt was due
for a radical reinvention and Ron
stepped up for the challenge yo oh
rhone's commuter shirt is the most
comfortable breathable and flexible
shirt known to man and here's why
rhone's comfortable four-way stretch
fabric provides breathability and
flexibility that leaves you free to
enjoy what life throws your way from
your commute to work to 18 holes on the
golf course it's time to feel confident
with a wrinkle-free shirt without any
hassle okay I hate traffic sweat the
common cold strong wind bugs cats pointy
objects in general filth but one thing
that I hate that I don't always talk
about is wrinkles and I cannot stand
taking the time to iron my shirt when
I'm going to work or dinner or wherever
it is and I sit there and I put the
starch on it and I'm not great at it but
I do it and I put in the time and what
happens you put the button-down shirt on
you put your arms in and the second you
bend your arms your arms look like
accordions and I cannot stand it and
this eliminates that they have wrinkle
release technology they disappear as you
stretch and wear the shirt they don't
get worse they get less with gold Fusion
anti-order technology which is another
thing I said sweat is that that I hate
you'll be smelling fresh and clean all
day long on top of that road is 100
machine washable so you can ditch the
dry cleaner all together and same save
some sugar all right
uh they sent me some samples I love them
truly you really can wear them to lunch
or to a funeral or to a date or to a
board meeting really and you'll feel
fresh and you'll feel good and
comfortable uh the commuter sure can get
you through any work day and straight
into whatever comes next that's their
big signature item the commuter shirt
head to rhone.com tastebuds and use the
promo code taste buds to get 20 off your
entire order that's 20 off your entire
order when you head to Rhone r h o n
e.com slash taste buds and use code
taste buds it's time to find your corner
office comfort
who wants better sex
I see all of you raising your hands
let's talk Adam and Eve okay the best
way to get started is to go to
adamandeve.com right now Adam and Eve is
offering 55-0 off of just about any item
more than that Adam and Eve wants to
make your life easy they offer discreet
shipping as your privacy is a priority
plus free shipping on your entire order
so it's going to be discreet okay
doesn't matter how much you spend or
what you buy it'll all be packaged
discreetly and it'll be sent to you for
free okay bring more pleasure and
satisfaction into your bedroom just go
to adamandeve.com and select any one
item it could be an adventurous new toy
or anything you desire just enter the
offer code taste buds to check out and
you'll get 50 off of almost any item on
that site and when you do you'll also
get free shipping in your entire order
when you enter the offer code taste buds
that's taste buds so it's
c-a-s-t-e-b-u-d-s adamandeve.com this is
an exclusive offer specific to this
podcast so be sure to use the code taste
buds to get not just a discount but also
a hundred percent free shipping I'm
intrigued I'm gonna check it out
adamandeve.com free shipping code taste
buds
when you have a kid you the baby you
have to I know you have to roll it raise
my sister yeah because I I know friends
who had their kids there to put things
on their baby's helmet because it comes
out first it comes out like it's coming
through the Plato Fun Factory
mushy so my mother because my I have a
bald head she goes thank me for that
because I rolled you every 20 minutes is
that is that how often you have to do it
she did she's a [ __ ] psycho that
sounds like a lot she was so worried
about my head she has to turn your head
this way she had to turn me this way
turn me that way I have to make sure
you're not sleeping like this because
then it dense in right it's gonna get
wild you ever see that you ever see the
guy with just a flat back no you never
saw that no next time look at it as a
child uh yeah that never caused
corrected that no it doesn't well you
have to wear a helmet when you're a kid
but why not wear the helmet get rid of
that you can't do it later in life your
skull is hard no look yeah oh it makes
me sad uh why'd you bring up the kids
bring up the guys
oh there you go right there there you go
look at that
oh wow yeah
oh that's a lot that's significant yeah
it's bad well you know when I got really
big I was like 350 at my biggest no [ __ ]
a really big dude big dangerous I was
gonna [ __ ] I was gonna die but the back
of my head my kid used to call his his
uh Cinnabon and he used to bite it what
the [ __ ] because all the wrinkles look
like a Cinnabon and he would go Dad I
gotta get some
I'm like all right go ahead and go ha
and he just bite the back of my head so
I missed that he goes my cinnabon's gone
I said oh so sad
how cute is that
uh he knows your head's not food though
yeah he knows my hair you're not a [ __ ]
he's not [ __ ] yes I don't know yeah
he's not yeah I don't know that's how I
feed him yeah I rub I put sugar on the
back of my neck be great that he
understands to trust because you have to
build relationships but then he doesn't
understand that the back of your head is
not a confectionary treat I'm sure that
that stuff like that about social media
at all yeah yeah I I put him on my thing
fun stuff he loves stuff like that I
mean my my kid loves he's funny he's got
a sense of humor I don't put my wife at
all on she's never what you put are you
afraid of his relationship no he's gotta
he's got a a YouTube page where he does
science experiments that all his friends
I made him a science table and my wife
was like I want a science table so I was
like all right [ __ ] so I made it yeah
you're handy right I'm handy I guess I
would call you I'm a man did you build a
pirate ship in New York I built the
pirate ship yeah yeah yeah that's handy
that's being a man well that's a shot at
me then because I have trouble hang and
picture frames I'm a different type of
man no I'm sorry I didn't know I thought
you're gonna be like yeah I can build a
house from scratch yeah me and your dad
a man yeah yeah you're a [ __ ] boy
that's in now that's the thing yeah I
embrace no my dick is right now yeah
yeah I'm out with you I'm not even in
commercials anymore
yeah
yeah your dad like you know that that's
the new face of Crystal Light you should
be there you should take it away from
them you know what I mean I imagine you
just jumping in the pool just like yeah
jump into the pool throwing Crystal
Light in my face you should yeah you're
at the gym with five pound dumbbells
[Laughter]
um yeah your dad can build houses huh
yeah yeah he was a carpenter and he was
like a HVAC guy and a loves sanitation
man and he did all that kind of stuff
Carpenters fascinate me yeah that these
guys just learned how to build something
yeah I don't get it he used to like
knock down walls in our house and like
build new ones and stuff and I don't
know how do you do that yeah you just
how do you how do you learn to do that
how did you learn I learned
my my stepdad Larry he worked at a
lumber yard or whatever but you know
anytime something had to be done
we just did it you know he wanted you
know he's Italian you know so of course
all the grass had to go out of the
backyard and we had a cemented cemented
yeah put a deck and above ground pool
and you just kind of like he just would
go he'd have this stuff dropped off and
we'd just do it and he has a friend to
tell you what to do he'd be like do this
dude yeah you just do this you got this
how you do it so when I got a house my
wife was like we need a fence so I just
went on YouTube that's awesome the same
thing that's an insane thing what to be
like I need to build a fence and look on
YouTube and then build a fence uh yeah
because there's got to be things that
like that's beyond my can you do that
you handy if I had YouTube I could do it
you think you could you don't have
YouTube well I used to have to be an
assistant on sets and like help build
okay yeah yeah I I go to YouTube because
I I have a learning disability I can't I
have dyslexia I can't read I can't
absorb what I read well but I absorb
very quickly videos okay so if you tell
me something once I build the gun
cabinet I built a safe the shed I have I
did all the the interior but it's all
from YouTube my my heat went out in the
middle of February last year yeah it
went out
okay and I called the guy and he's like
250 to come out 250 an hour and I was
like you know Screw you right and uh I
just went on YouTube and there was a guy
with a hair lip it was like Snap you
know goodness I had to watch like 17
extra heat off a YouTube video off a
YouTube video there was one screw I had
to take all the stuff off and then there
was a screw go like that put it back no
way [ __ ] don't go kick back on yeah
no [ __ ] 100 save myself a thousand
dollars yeah
when you're going to be like all right I
got to build a shed yeah how do you know
find that you know how to nail something
into each other or saw something but how
do you know the inventory of what kind
of planks you need and you got to go you
gotta how do you know the measure
soundly soundly load bearing how do you
know it's sound how the physics behind
it did the engineering behind no no no
frame I don't know I don't build a shed
I built the pirate ship but I don't know
that I mean it could be 10 kids in that
and they all die okay okay that's a
risky day okay yeah yeah yeah yeah like
when I put my fence up you know you this
is what you need as a comic there's a
difference between a comic man like you
know that and a regular man so every
comic guy like you need all you need is
a real man friend I have a real man
friend okay big shoulders Joe okay Joe
Giordano he's my man friend he's got
guns he's got a Range Rover you know he
right so when I call him he's like he's
the guy's like good you should do uh you
know do something over here right and
I'm like you know so I'll I'll go with
him but like girls you do is this and
I'll go to the YouTube I'll watch a guy
he'll come over and help me you know put
stuff together how satisfying is it when
you decide to do a project like that and
you see it to completion and then you
could just I mean it must feel like
amazing oh dude when you cook uh I used
to cook I feel like that's the same
thing I don't cook and I can't do this
but I feel like imagine like finishing
an amazing meal for people or building
like a pirate ship and then you're done
yeah it's like the closest I come to
that is finishing like a Lego set well
that's one of my life my God my wife
loves me yeah yeah my wife's you know
her she gets hard nips when I she goes
you decided Well I need us I want to
sound like size table for Max woodwork I
came out the thing pops up I got a side
shelf and it says Max and wood has his
name on it it's got lights are you going
the extra mile no because I like doing
it I like building [ __ ] I like making
[ __ ] like when we go I got I got a
shotgun and I had to build a gun safe so
I made this whole wooden cabinet she's
like I need a bookshelf for mask we went
Max we went to get them then a thousand
dollars yeah a wood bookshelf is a
thousand dollars [ __ ] I just went
and bought the wood and I built it I
mean it cost me seven thousand dollars
I built it you know what I mean when
you're shooting shotguns you hunt I
bought a little hunt with a shotgun do
you no you no you don't you can but you
shouldn't are you bird
um you're shooting birds with shotguns
absolutely yeah you want to spread you
want to spread so when it flies up you
and it spreads and it's a little tiny
pillow game like pheasants like what do
you shoot yeah not a sparrow
you would a turkey a pheasant yeah all
that stuff with a shotgun you shot a
pheasant no you you'll get you're
getting ahead of me because you [ __ ]
freaking out a pheasant is foul right
yeah any any any Turk any any bird any
bird that you can yes
I don't know now you got your presence
was a specific bird no foul foul is a
bird it's all birds a bird of order of
blood it keeps eggs yeah so one that has
eggs and flesh fouls there you go right
there foul of birds belonging to one of
the two biological orders namely the
game foul the landfall and the waterfowl
anatomical and molecular similarity
suggest these two groups are closely
ever related uh I still that doesn't
mean anything to me I learned nothing
Birds collectively especially yeah
that's foul but what a pheasant is a
specific you shot what
listen I've I shot a squirrel and a
chipmunk no you didn't Bob I killed both
no you didn't involve come on no no did
you speak to you I'm going to tell you
right now you're lying now
mine was yours was murdered yours was
murder and you got cold feet I swear to
God I've never killed a squirrel a
chipmunks okay I was joke lying okay
okay well you're gonna ruin my trust in
you now not because I came out I [ __ ]
immediately said I wasn't lying I was
lying a chipmunk I mean I didn't kill
him imagine gunning down a squirrel with
a shotgun no but I will have to kill
Chipmunks why because they'll they'll
[ __ ] eat through them where are we in
this because we got to get to battle
time we're about 40 35 oh my God all
right we have to at some point battle
turkey club versus sloppy joe
and that's going to start in a moment we
should move on to the battle but but all
right but have you what have you shot
with the shotgun I've shot nothing
nothing yet targets okay it's from home
protection but how do you shoot a Target
if it's a spray well you didn't say did
you see this what you're happening
you're going all
up you're taking
instead of my wife okay
you went forward in your head you asked
me do you have a gun and I said yes I do
oh yeah and he's shotgun what are you
sure I said foul you shoot Birds no I
said you asked what you shoot with
shotguns okay I said what guys shoot
with chocolate okay and they shoot birds
and then you should follow us follow all
birds I was like I don't [ __ ] know I
never shot the shotgun I've shot
shotguns I've shot Clays I know how to
shoot a gun okay but my shotgun thank
God I haven't used it because it's for
home protection so if I use it that
means there'd be some Dead Guy okay in
my kitchen so no I haven't shot this
shotgun where's the shotgun stay the
stuff
tell me if
[Laughter]
birthday candles
Bobby
I learned that on the good doctor
I love that show tell us more about this
show
I forgot about my special my special
shotgun and it's locked so then if you
hear an intruder you got to get to the
no the the bullets you always keep a gun
loaded you never keep a gun unloaded in
your house
the safety's on right but you keep that
sucker loaded yeah that there's there's
there's five shots in it ready to go
five in a row and it's cocked I just
gotta turn the safety off boom let me
ask you a question because I thought
about this in my head yes because I've
never really lived in a place where I
was like usually it's been apartment
buildings or I live with some of those
security never been like in a place
where I was like all right it's just me
and that's it yep and I was thinking
about if I ever wanted to get protection
now in New York which you don't live in
New York right I live in Westchester I
actually live in here oh you do I live
in best Chester right I live where you
should you can't shoot somebody Jersey I
went up there westchester's like Jersey
you you so you can't shoot somebody in
your house
they have to be coming towards you but
don't they have to have a weapon I um
do you have a weapon to plant on that
yeah I have to say that
I know well I mean as they're coming
towards you you have to say please don't
please don't please don't yeah I'm
playing and you should [ __ ] it hopefully
they leave and if they keep coming you
can you can shoot them okay you can't
shoot them in the back okay if they're
walking away like they're leaving you
you know you gotta flip them over right
you know but I've got friends up there
too so I kind of know what to do all
right the scenario if you shoot them
like if I and you kind of pull them in
you know what I mean pull them into the
house right right like he's a vampire I
might have might not have a buck knife
right you know with them duct tape on it
that might be you know I've watched
enough movies in the 80s and 90s you're
ready to know listen let me ask you this
I thought of the sun now are you
prepared and I think that you won't know
until the moment yeah but obviously if
you are in immediate danger or
especially your wife or child yeah
there's no question you're going to
shoot this person 100
but you will end up shooting and
probably killing a person yeah I have no
problem with that you have no problem
that's at that point I have no problem
I've made peace with that you go forward
being like that person was about to I'm
not one [ __ ] if you come in and
[ __ ] threaten my family whatsoever if
you come into my house yes and by
threatening my family if you come after
me I'm the breadwinner right you're
threatening my [ __ ] family protect
you know my I got to be here for my kid
that's why I lost the weight um he's not
living my life right you come you're
gone you're gone and if I don't have a
gun I'll I'll cut your head off and hold
your head up and hand it to the cops
right I'm that guy you know what I mean
yeah if you threaten those two so let me
ask you this I mean if someone came in
right now yeah and threatened you too
I'd be like hey man I'm gonna check um
but do you then feel like you'd have to
move immediately because there was a a
murderer at your house that you will
never be able to not look like no this
is cleaning services that will come and
clean it up but you're not gonna but you
can't but you can't still live there
where you blew away a stranger so I'll
put a [ __ ] Memorial right there are
you serious yeah I'll leave the shotgun
unloaded right there I'll get a brand
new shotgun trophy like no I beat the
gold like a karate trophy so that's
where I that's where I have trouble I'm
like I wouldn't want to kill the person
in the place where I don't want to move
from like I love this house I don't want
to move from my house if I kill this guy
in this house I can't stay here I'm not
gonna stay here when this guy was dead
right there and then just just just
Swiffer it up and then watch the good
doctor after that put put duct tape
around like a crime scene yeah that'd be
awesome all right you know every every
year have a memorial put little flowers
up like on the side of the highway okay
I can see that I mean all right I get
some get some uh some hors d'oeuvres out
remember [ __ ] uh [ __ ] Charles
whatever his name was that came in yeah
all right have his family over I'll have
to think about that then yeah I need to
take your attitude huh would you make it
100 would you make it a bit oh you got
you got it there's no way around it man
as a comic yeah I mean first of all bits
come so hard it's so hard to get a bit
and the only way really bits work with
guys like us is if they're real yeah
they have some if they have some truth
into it yeah I can't write I can't I'm
not smart enough to just say man
wouldn't this be funny if a guy broken I
couldn't do that I don't have that right
it has to affect me emotionally speaking
of bits yes you have it because we got
to get to this battle but I also want to
make sure we plug the special that was
great because I'm excited for it tell us
about the special about where can I find
it Louis ck.com he directed produced it
and who is that uh he's
the Best comedian he's one of the best
comedians to walk in the world he's a
redheaded Mexican it's really weird
that's true
Okay cool so it's so he produced he
threw me who's that does he not know
that big where he doesn't know what
Louie is I should have come to that son
of a [ __ ]
um yeah he came up to me I did a little
tour with him he was like where's your
special I go I don't have one he goes
you need a spec you have to have a
special you should have a special of
course and I was like yeah well you know
a lot of the times change you know what
I mean Netflix and all these you know
comedy Central's gone and people you
know whatever and I was like yeah I just
nobody really wants a middle-aged white
dude [ __ ] my perspective which is
fine I get it and uh he's like I'm gonna
do it and I was like fine and he
actually you know Louie if he says he's
gonna do something he does it and you
know his thing was you know because I
have a whole thing on weight loss I was
doing uh for a while and uh he was like
I don't want to do that because I don't
want to do like a theme thing now you
can save that do that next or whatever
he goes do you have an hour of just
killing and I was like yeah I have two
hours of material that right I had to
keep and I you know I never got rid of
because I kind of piece mailed it out
here yeah yeah he's like I want to do
that so I was like all right great we
found this place uh in Tampa he was like
what do you want to do it Boston I go no
Tampa because Tampa Florida saved my
life during the pandemic is that right
100 because it was the only place I can
go and do gigs and these fans just love
me down okay and that they're just great
Side Splitters uh McCurdy's vasanis so
uh and Mike Carlton my number one best
friend is down there and you know he
saved my life too I mean I mean this is
where it had to be sure and I called his
band I go I want you to open up the show
we found this place called when did you
shoot it Coastal creatives we shot it in
uh I believe March okay and um we went
in it's a blank space it's a studio
space and we made it into
uh this kill box because I told them I
like I was thinking Elvis's 68 special
you know when he that square yeah it's
just him in the middle of yeah yeah I go
I want every I want people all around me
but not in the round you know I want I
want to create this oh yeah this that
throws me this I love it I want you
right there I want to see when you
didn't like it when you liked it you
liked I want all right behind you dude
every shot not be right behind me yeah
but like almost yeah yeah like almost
every shot is crowd and me okay oh
that's cool which I love that's really
cool and uh and we created this little
you know like you're at the comedy cell
it's a kill box Side Splitters it's just
it's just something about it that you
have all these people up on you a
theater there's always 10 feet away yeah
there's some there is something I get it
oh yeah they're awesome but that I
wanted everything connects like that and
we CR we did it and uh filmed it uh it
was crazy too the first show
uh I'm all ready to go and some they see
you know Mike called this band Pitbull
titles up there Donna they made a riff
for me so Tampa rock and roll just a
bunch of chubby guys and Titans you know
what I mean ladies and gentlemen it's my
[ __ ] best friend Robert Kelly I'm
walking out some drunk chick
sorry um what the [ __ ] was that birth
control
birth control I gotta take my birth
control
football is
you go build all the pirate ships you
want buddy I don't even know what
happened to Matt Jones last week I heard
he hurt his ankle I don't even follow I
didn't I don't know did he yeah I heard
it I think he broke it he broke his
ankle well then I'm out of the loop a
bit yeah he's out um so anyways we did
that date it was great Show's a great a
lady almost died on the first show which
was nuts 20 minutes on stage killing I
hear help her
I swear to god dude I ignored it and
then I heard please help her I looked
there was a lady like this no and her
husband please
look at all the taping Bobby I'm like
I'm I'm doing my special you [ __ ] we had
to stop dude lights went up no shares
went on stage I I was off stage like
back at the door when I came how far in
first taping 20 minutes first I'm like
20 minutes into the first taping
um
start over or no dude I'm sick for
around 15 minutes this is going on
trying to get this lady out she doesn't
I mean all the chairs are on my stage
this perfect [ __ ] stage everybody the
lights are on I'm in the back people are
looking at me I'm panicking I got an
immediate eye headache my eye just went
[ __ ] you yeah and then I look 15 minutes
Louis looks over him he goes we're good
we're good I'm like I'm not [ __ ] good
right right right so I went up
I had to start up I mean and I had her
you know us we had to acknowledge it I'm
getting laughs and then I had to I don't
even know where I was so I I look at I I
know that I killed for the rest of the
set yeah you know but I I was in my head
because I didn't understand what how
much time yeah it was hot and dude I
came off I'm in the back room cleared
the back I'm sitting there like this
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] it's [ __ ] I was
[ __ ] yeah I just wrote the first show
is always the one yeah second one is
always the hey man do whatever you want
you got it and you got yeah I'm like
[ __ ] me oh my God if I don't get this
I'm [ __ ] right uh and Louis was back
there and he's like it's okay man he
cleared everybody out Louie gave me
my God he gave me a JFK Martin Luther
King Malcolm X speech really and then it
wasn't working then he goes he broke out
a Tom Brady inspirational clip no [ __ ]
no [ __ ]
I swear to God he goes watch this no one
wanted me
he didn't think I had it I could run
fast enough and it worked I was like
[ __ ] I could do this let's go do it I
was like come on yeah and we went out
and we nailed this oh that's awesome I
can't wait to see it yeah it looks
beautiful what's it called it's called
kill box oh right on yeah that's fun so
uh it's beautifully shot and he's such a
genius man it's like you don't
understand like they they did he brought
his crew in like his award-winning
people that do his special yeah Leah his
this you know his manager assistant
executive producer who helps him do all
his crew his set designer this guy has
Awards yeah and and Louie that's all
they set all the thing up they go try it
out I get on stage I am in like this is
this is it guys you did it like this was
in my brain and you you made it happen
and then Louie comes in and goes yeah
this is wrong this is right and I'm like
what and he goes I need move that why
why can we get all right I need we need
60 more seats over here we need 70 seats
put more tickets on sale Bobby call Mike
get we got to sell more tickets put it
on your Instagram sell more tickets
let's go and he's like okay yeah 30
minutes goes by he made everything so
much better yeah and you need to be able
to see that right as the Director he saw
that and he's editing it too so it's
great because he's like he's like dude
this is killing well we're making like
we just wants bits that kill so there's
some if crowd work kills he leaves it
yeah because comedy Center yeah why not
edit it right Comedy Central only yet it
but also Comedy Central will you know we
we're leaving in it's a it's the [ __ ]
it's a killer Club set that's what this
special is this isn't the swooping yeah
thing this isn't the you know the the
typical shots with the curtain in the
background and me this is a [ __ ] a
club
special how do people get it to go to
Louis ck.com October 8th October it's
available Louis ck.com and uh I'm I'm
very excited and please buy it because I
have to pay Louie back for spending his
money yeah really yeah it's gonna suck
me on the road with him not getting any
money you guys ready for Louie [ __ ]
30-year vet you wanna see my special
no I'm just like to see if you guys for
some reason don't know Bobby is he's
truly a legend yeah one of the funniest
Comics ever so check that out we didn't
battle at all
[Music]
you remember you were there you were
there one of the first times we've ever
had a big brawl about food yes it was
also on the cruise yes we were backstage
yeah and we're fighting over Oreo versus
chips 100 and I forgot you were there
and it was Versi was there yep and we
were all going at it yeah Joe DeRosa got
drunk pushed everybody at the crap table
Yeah Yeah I never win
[Laughter]
actually I actually
um my lady recorded it yeah and I have
the video of us screaming again I've had
many of those with DeRosa I love DeRosa
many many of the when I because I relate
to this podcast because I've been where
you're at right with DeRosa right uh I
mean
real I think we had a chicken McNugget
fight once yeah we had a hash brown
fight McDonald's came up without Joe
even being here
Joe's brought up McDonald's in 104
episodes straight we had it
he lives alone
he was gonna cook every night that's sad
I'm gonna make a ham I'm gonna leave his
friends are the cast of cactus from the
McDonald's like that's who is he has a
great imaginary yeah yeah I uh we we had
one of our big fights was over hash
browns yeah Denny's hash the hash brown
yeah or the McDonald's hash brown yeah
or the Denny's you know shredded hat
yeah you know so all the cube potato
hash browns yeah which one where are you
I dude I'm uh
I like the cube potato hash browns the
cubes yeah that's fun they're all good I
like a hash brown you like the shredded
uh well if it's like I love that top
layer you like the crunchy crispy yeah
and then like the soft is underneath but
I just eat the crisp on the top yeah but
you're gonna say that with the potatoes
you got to say listen you uh I want you
to burn these I say it I'm gonna say it
don't I say it I lock eyes because they
won't burn they won't burn it I go
excuse me if it's pizza if it's toasters
I go excuse me I go can you please burn
my toast yeah um I know that you're
gonna tell them to burn it and they
might take care of your word or not I
know that they're going to think it's
burnt when it's not really burnt they
don't want to burn it and send it out
because they feel bad about it I will
not send it back please burn the goddamn
toast it's not burnt yeah I do the same
thing with hash browns I go burn it and
then burn it again and then when you
think it's really burnt when you're like
this guy's a [ __ ] lunar I say that
this guy's nuts burn it more I say that
on the ordering pizza I go when you
think that it's too much like double
that yeah are you like your pizza crust
I like your burnt apparently though
there's carcinogens in that who gives a
[ __ ] um
Pizza yeah I know I don't want that I
don't want if you want I like feeling
like tasting that like Char yeah the
Char and the Crunch and you barbecuing
stuff right of course you put a nice
barbecue so is that not good for us to
char No who said that you camp too we
have a lot to talk about you should come
back I will come back we're not finished
right now we're gonna fight about this
all right let's fight let's all right I
I text you some stuff you threw me a
bunch of stuff one of them was Turkey
Club turkey club we've never done a
turkey club That's a classic sandwich
we've never done on the podcast I tried
to think of something that could go up
against that I love a sloppy joe I don't
have them often I have fond memories of
them I think they're do you not know
what a sloppy joe is 100 know what it is
but it's a it's a gimmick no it's it's a
gimmick I don't think okay okay let's
let's go at it though okay let's go I
think turkey Club is is very vanilla I
think it's an Old Faithful but I think
it's boring I think that I I think that
um
I think that
I've never had a turkey club that was
like this is lights out good
it's always like
just a little dry it kind of falls apart
it's the bread and the bread again and
it's okay but it's I think it's a lot of
smoke and mirrors it's not a lot of
turkey on there first of all is a
classic nighttime sandwich okay I do
love a frilly toothpick it's got toast
yeah you got the furly toothpaste it's
it's in four quarters and it's stacked
so you can eat you can you what you
supposed you can you can make every any
variation of that sandwiches you want
you could do some bacon you first of all
you need mayonnaise you need extra
mayonnaise and you can make a little BLT
you can have a little turkey you can
make sure you're making side sandwiches
yeah it's so you're pulling out turkey
dipping in the Mayo and just eating the
lettuce the BL and the tea you can do
whatever you want it's not just one
sandwich it's like uh it's it's multi
sandwich it's modular yeah that's why
it's great and it always comes with
[ __ ] fries fries So you you're making
little sandwiches you're getting a
little bit it's a fun dishes it's a
nighttime
classic they can't mess it up you're not
going to get food a lot of times turkey
club is a go-to on a room service menu
yeah a lot of times I'll order it and a
turkey club has let me down so many
times because they can sometimes there's
not enough turkey sometimes there's too
much turkey where they do that thing
where it's like this big and you're like
taking half the turkey out and you're
biting it sometimes that's really
toothpick will hit you right in the gums
too there's no such thing as a too much
turkey that is nuts but it's like it's
you can't take the turkey out that's
it's a modular sandwich no I know but
now you're removing turkey in order to
eat remove Turkey leave it over here you
get to eat that turkey later I get that
you're in your room you come back from a
show uh nothing I got my turkey you have
the leftover turkey the leftover turkey
you got the turkey
the Kentucky
because I don't like to eat right before
a show yeah so all the room service if I
don't finish it I don't put it outside I
keep it down right there but it ends up
being like five or six hours later and
then you come and you open the thing
back up you're like you can't do that
with a burger finish the rest of this
you can't do that with a [ __ ] sloppy
Joe sloppy joe hot only
I don't agree have you well have you
ever gone to the other side oh have you
ever had a sloppy joe that that it was
warm or even cold buddy you cannot eat
look at oh
a sloppy joe nut first of all first of
all that's the worst that's the worst
game
sloppy joe nuts yes and I would never
put spiced beef sugar and sweet I get it
I get I get sugar and sweet but beef on
a donut this is why sloppy joe stinks it
just sucks no sloppy joe is actually
delicious I I I've only had sloppy joe
we didn't make sloppy joes on the
regular when I was little so they they
were like that's America look at that
sandwich that's a turkey club but it's
so it almost has the red white and blue
it's like look at all that
you talked about fun things about the
turkey club what about the fun things of
the sloppy joe just by name only just
the essence of it it's gonna be a sloppy
sandwich it's gonna be delicious that's
fine
okay sloppy joe comes shop can you
please show me a picture of a sloppy joe
steaming look at that extra sloppy look
at that look at that look at that oh
that's so good you want a sloppy Joe
it's been so long yeah they want one
when you take a bite of it it all mushes
out and it's just [ __ ] wet bread and
everything else is on the plane
100. you can take the bread and dip it
right in on that sloppy Joe it's not a
sandwich at that point it's sauce no no
no buddy you're crazy first of all you
can get as much sloppy as you need in
the mountain some comes out
the side it's by Design dude make a
sloppy joe bun with a hole not the
sloppy
you can't even order one on a date you
look like a [ __ ] Savage I I don't I
don't know of a more fun food to order
on a on a from a restaurant or if I was
at like some a friend's house or my
grandma's house or a friend and they're
like oh it's football Sunday what are
you gonna have wings no and someone goes
no no we're gonna make a tray of sloppy
joke yeah we're gonna make a sloppy joes
and you're gonna ruin your pants and
it's gonna get on your new sneakers and
my couch and the dogs gonna die because
there's onions in it who are you how do
you eat it how do you eat a meal you're
gonna get it all over the place it's a
sloppy [ __ ] job you said it yeah
you're an adult you're not sitting in a
high chair what are you talking about a
bite and let it fall into the place who
wants the food that's supposed to be in
your mouth on the plane
you remove the turkey from your turkey
[Music]
I like that I have no choice of the
matter it's how the sandwich the
sandwich dictates how it goes
literally there's no curveball if the
greatest Chef came in here made you a
turkey club it would taste like the
turkey club from the diner okay okay
sloppy joe people have their own secret
recipes for it some are heavy on the
spices some are heavy on the onions it
is so much sweet some are more Tangy
garbage people food and here's the thing
garbage yeah
I would love a fried chicken with the
corn and the brownie on the side with
them fried chicken last for seven years
I don't know listen it's not good I
don't need any more but why everybody's
dying to cancer
[Laughter]
it was good I didn't like the raspberry
when they tried to hit with the
raspberry compote instead of the brownie
but you still tasted it I hate it yeah
of course I did yeah and the little
cardboard lid that you flipped over and
had all the uh condensation on it and
then you scrape the uh potato off of the
thing because it burnt on the top oh
that was good I know yeah that was good
on it I did but I was sick about the
stupid sloppy joe which is disgusting
and see on those soft potato rolls oh
the Hawaiian rolls God yeah but but you
get nothing in a bite
you do though you do not the point about
the sloppy joe the reason it's sloppy
I'll tell you about the reason it's
sloppy is not because of the chopped
meat because I can put a manageable
amount of chopped meat on a bun and I
can make it so that it's not going to go
all over your pants like you just said
but the point of subject is you put way
too much on there yeah because you want
it overflowing yeah because you want to
bite it here if you want to bite a
little with a fork you want to sound
something it's just sloppy eating
experience but it's contained it's not
contained because most of the sloppy joe
doesn't get in the sandwich okay it gets
on the plate and you got to get a fork
or a spoon and the bread I I never said
The Taste is amazing okay and that's
another reason why you're going on
you're gonna finish sloppy jokes that's
another experience that's another reason
why it's [ __ ] [ __ ] sorry because I
want to eat it I want to eat what you
advertise I want to eat the chicken
sandwich that they put on the billboard
when I see a sloppy Joe and it's this
big I want to bite into that right and
have that experience but you bite into
it and it's air I don't don't get that
experience
you don't get anything you get it dude
you bite it and it mushes out I know but
but but the excess does I don't want
nothing it's like when you're spackling
you know you just run the edges let it
fall in and then the most of it comes
out and it's this what it should do they
should put the sloppy joe on the side
where it's gonna go anyways after the
first bite and then show you the
sandwich when it's a little thin
sandwich okay because that's what it
becomes a little thin sandwich with
sauce so a sloppy joe I love it that's
why it's made for pulling apart and
running through this
you know what that is when you're
sopping up that's down don't pull your
Italian okay if I know you're half
Italian yeah I'm half Italian too Scott
belly you know what that is
there's a restaurant Manhattan well
there's it's all over a town is called
Scarpetta right and they won't let you
know that when you go in there you know
what scrap that is it's when you take
the it's the term for when you take the
you clean your plate with the bread
right at the end yeah and that's not at
the beginning right but that's right but
my point is that's even a coined term
from Italian cuisine because the process
of doing that the food is so good you
love sopping it up with are you a sloppy
joe is that Joe is Italian no what I'm
saying is because it's it's good down to
I clean my plate with a slime sloppy Joe
was made by Cisco for kids
okay they made a gimmick sandwich and
now let's see what it says here what is
it why do they call a sloppy joe it had
nothing to do with the sandwich nope
the name was adopted by Jose Garcia
rios's Havana Club which sold liquor and
iced Seafood because the floor was
always wet with melted ice the patrons
taunted his Spanish Joe with running a
sloppy place
so that even defeats your your theory
that can't be right your theory is done
so now it's just a [ __ ] sandwich Cuba
well about Cuba's now it's just a messy
no it's damaged no no you're saying the
whole thing was sloppy that you said
that was against you what you said use
what you you just you just dictated the
whole sandwich as a sloppy mess for
garbage people right meanwhile it's not
even cold out because it's sloppy it's
called that because it's the moniker of
the guy who owned the restaurant 100 so
it's still a sloppy mess yeah let's just
say it both work
a turkey club is so boring I'm gonna ask
you a question right now let me ask you
a question I want to ask you a question
well I'll answer you questions
all right just show it it's your [ __ ]
place go ahead no because now I don't
want to do it now because you're making
me you're out for mailing me and I don't
wanna know you guys
you go are you kidding me you you you go
build your pirate ship you go first
alpha male
I skip
I like to skip
what
[ __ ] you alpha male no dude blame it are
you gonna let me go I'm gonna go are you
gonna go you go you go you go because I
forgot my question now I got my question
go ahead all right truth yes what
percentage of the times you order a
turkey club does it come dry as [ __ ]
because there's nothing worse than that
carved turkey that feels like these
little cardboard
a turkey club can be a travesty if it's
dry you want the truth yes 96.5 of the
time it's dry but that's why that's so
much okay that's why you can put the man
in okay that's why you have the Tomato
immediately need to correct the sandwich
that you ordered you know you need to
not at all you when you have to solve
for dry you have a car outside if
there's no gas in it it looks pretty but
you need to add something else to it to
make it right that's that's sounds like
a crock of horseship it's not a cracker
it's fat so so you have to add Mayo
otherwise you make it right
look you have to add me yeah
you have to add Mayo otherwise your
sandwich is inedible no no inedible I
don't know nobody cares not edible
and if you're in a jam mustard
mustard on a turkey club in a jam never
heard of it in a jam
in a jam I said I just agreed that the
church and I really respect that he
agreed that the turkey club when he
orders it is dried probably 96.5 what's
the time 100 you know what's never dry
it's impossible sloppy joe yeah you know
it's never in your mouth sloppy joe
it's not on it's not in the sandwich
it's not a sandwich all right ready it's
not a sandwich all right let me just say
something here's my question here's my
question please ask it okay you on a
date New York City Diner no I'm not
ordering a turkey club either oh Diner
you got they're like hey are we at the
first date it's a second date second
your second day
what do you think hey guys sorry we got
uh turkey club and sloppy joes what time
is it
just sloppy joe turkey club time who
I'm with
that's the owner I'm the owner what
nationality was that what nationality
yeah but cross between Italian Lebanese
and Jewish a cross between yeah my wife
was Jewish in Lebanese and I'm Italian
all right and my mom was my mom [ __ ]
the guy in Lebanon and then that's it
and then that thing then you get a diner
that's how it works yeah and Greek I
have Greek in me too so so you're
telling me on a second date second date
sorry we only have a turkey club it's a
little dry it's a little dry but I have
mayonnaise yeah and a sloppy joe what
would you like to get on a second date
now why wouldn't they order the sloppy
joe because you'd look like an ass no I
wouldn't I want I gotta be myself if you
I know
you're out of your mind you're right
speaking it out of there mine
sloppy joe a turkey club what's up pick
one buddy
that's it
give me get out of here kid gimmick yeah
he probably you probably like Edibles
too Lunchables oh oh no no I argued
against lunch wait did I already no I
argued four of course you did you like
sloppy jokes like Lunchables versus
um we did it with the all you Garbage
Guys I a Lunchable I like a of course
the little juices you love a gimmick
meal no I love an adult meal a turkey
club I'll tell you right now if if if we
were about to have a meal uh we were
about to eat after this before we left
right and be honest and I put down a
piping hot sloppy joe plate and a turkey
club plate wouldn't you be like turkey
club a hundred times I have Sloppy Joe
like 1 to 100 versus wouldn't you choose
a sloppy joe no because I like these
pants
you can't trust yourself not to get slop
on this it's a [ __ ] mess it's an
abortion on a bun
that's harsh it's terrible that's harsh
it's terrible and and you're talking I
love that you add people make their own
space it's a packet a pre-made packet
from a company with with poison in it if
you want it you put it in there and you
put it with hamburger it's the most easy
meal ever it's a package it's like an
opening it's like a Ramen College meal
what does it matter if you call it a
packet in the package a [ __ ] bird how
to die to make a turkey club and then
you had to have a farmer plant tomatoes
and lettuce and then you had to step
some old lady this tomato this tomatoes
in the in the slot you don't know that
it's onions we all make sacrifice for
the sandwiches haha
what do you want me to tell you I'm so
hungry right now I want a sloppy joke so
bad I would do it I'll be joking I think
in like 10 years I would do a sloppy joe
but I would dig the bread out so someone
would stay in what about that what what
about that opening a nice soft potato
roll bun scooping out the bread to make
a bowl like yeah thing if you will I'll
do that happy in there do that but why
can't you do it that way you could
choose how you want to eat it you just
told me that the turkey club was modular
and you'll take some turkey out eat it
and then save the other turkey for later
because it's a modular sandwich but you
can't adjust the way that you eat a
sloppy joe if you love a bowl out of
your bread make the bowl out of your
bread and boom now you're eating sloppy
joes now we're preparing Taste of taste
sloppy joe go [ __ ] yourself
I poked a hole in that good doctor go
five
we read some uh some comments here and
then we'll go to the voting so they
don't know that DeRosa they don't know
that Bobby is subbing for DeRozan so
they they always try to guess who did
what that's fine so this is Joe DeRosa
versus Turkey Club so that's way off
actually but sloppy joe is deroza every
morning after going on a bender that
sauce is like the vomit that dribbles
out of his mouth from the night before
[Music]
sloppy joes are yeah really sloppy joes
are a great sandwich if you have a
burning Marlboro in the ashtray next to
you
you just yelled you yelled turkey club
Ian yells turkey club and then takes out
a pack of red marble Redskins
what are you aiming for here in life
yeah what what are you aiming for in
Life That's Good Times
that's a dead end Road right no he's
trying to make it any way he can like
anything somebody's looking for he can
fit into what are you talking about I
like cowboy Killers I like Fiona a heavy
smoke that's not gonna get you nowhere
very fast what smoking cigarettes yeah
so is piling on Sloppy Joes what do you
think of that huh yeah I don't work in
clubs the way to go thank you very much
take your time
Marlboro Reds I just want you to you
sound like Bruce Valance
the reference you thought nobody was
gonna get earlier I forget I forget I
don't I don't have a memory look I mean
there is this oh my God oh my God
around
yeah
there's no way he's alive yeah he's
alive he looks different
if he's he's dead oh my God no he's not
dead no it says it right there
alive now he's alive Baby Alive oh he is
okay yes 73 God bless him oh my god wow
all right God bless anyway
let's go to the phones let's keep going
turkey club without a doubt sloppy joe
for kids and poor people Jesus
stay your fans you know what I'm glad
your fans are intelligent smart people
exactly you should have trailer home to
have a sloppy what does that matter for
the people that live in a trail home I I
would live in a trailer home let's not
tell the history of the club was uh from
country clubs that's what it was right
yeah I was going to ask you why it was
called the elitists yeah
this is a class this is class Warfare
right now a fancy sandwich this is the
one percenters versus everybody else
good people yours in country clubs yes
and mine gets served yeah at VFW
and you're screaming that from a
high-rise apartment
Jersey no
Sal would say this is a drubbing oh I
don't even want to look at the
percentages right now you came in here
and you just probably slaughtered me
turkey club sloppy joe sounds like a bad
oral sex name who voluntarily eats
something named after two gross words
sloppy and Joe DeRosa Jesus Christ a
turkey club sounds like a happening
place you can get a drink maybe dance a
little a sloppy joe reminds you that
Uncle you know the one
the turkey club sounds like a cool place
to go sloppy joe is someone who elicits
a gag response I'm this might be the
first to have a 100 to zero yeah nobody
likes a sloppy joe where are where are
the sloppy joe people they're dead
because we're meeting sloppy joes
it's it's him I remember what about the
Nostalgia
when was the last time couldn't tell you
couldn't tell you great doesn't that
excite you when was the last time you
had one I I got to think 10 years I have
one at schnitzers yeah you know why you
haven't won in 10 years because you grew
up no it's just I was it's in a sloppy
it's just
it's the basis of every other food you
like taco meat making a face if you if
you were married right yeah and would
you be like hey let's do sloppy joes
tonight hell yeah and you know what she
say hell [ __ ] know come on I'm not
making a mess in my kitchen make a
sloppy joe if you want to no she's a
good cook why would she make a sloppy
joe
it was a cheap version of a sloppy
it's called Chicken Cacciatore or uh uh
what's it American chop suey American
chop suey we've had American chop suey
are you out of your mind no are you
Italian I'm not even positive I know
what Chop Suey is American chop suey is
a song by System of a Down I thought so
American chop suey is ground beef sauce
mushrooms onions Peppers right
and you put you put it on pasta sloppy
Joe and pasta would be great look at
that look at that look at that look at
that that doesn't look good okay that's
Chop Suey that's Chop Suey I had no idea
I had no idea now that's a dish so
you'll take the meat that you're that
you're arguing the also your only
argument is that it falls off the bun
you would want it on pasta though it's
not if you put it on pasta I get a spoon
and I eat it and I get to taste it I put
it on a bun I take a bite it like falls
off I think that I think that you've
only made one argument against the
sloppy joe and I don't think it was a
strong one it's terrible the idea I'm
going to get ossified here so let's go
to the phones here this is the segment
we call Humble Pie where somebody has to
eat their words okay and uh it was a
cute little pun you know and uh pimpy
throw up the uh the record and the
breakdown of the uh voting here this is
gonna be better I'm not gonna look
drumroll
oh not as bad as I throw up a bed you
doubled me oh wow turkey club takes this
win 67.1 percent to 32.9 after 11 000
votes thank you very much everybody I
mean you came in yeah and you did your
thing I did my thing and uh I'm right on
this one Sal and you need to just accept
that turkey club is a is a classic
you're a man now I didn't think I was
gonna lose that bad I thought people
would have a a longing for the Joe
longing for the Joe
um go see me on tour salocado comedy.com
all my full dates are up right now merch
is on sale on our websites as well solo
pod everything Bobby uh get his special
October October 8th 8th Louis ck.com yes
absolutely Robert kellylive.com would be
everywhere all right so this is how we
end when the person who wins says to the
other person I still love you and then I
say I love you too so that's what you
guys say I still love you I love you too
Bob all right buddy see you next time
great cause they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right